Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie, Secret Invasion episodes have
started they recently released a promo with
Nick Fury talking about Shield Chloe Bennet's
Quake character was also recently featured in
Spider-Man across the spider verse of all places
and because of what's coming in Marvel phase six
and Beyond with the saber space station and
Marvel's story for that bringing so many of
the previous actors back like Charlie Cox all the
Daredevil Punisher characters a lot of you asked
about the Agents of Shield characters returning in
MCU projects so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel I'm doing videos for all
the secret Invasion episodes be sure to subscribe
to get them we're also doing a giveaway for Disney
plus memberships all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and let me know where you want to
see Quake come back in the MCU I'll name a new
winner during this video too I've tried to find
a couple sponsors to try and make that a little
bit easier to do every single week so thank you to
rage Shadow Legends for sponsoring this video raid
is one of the biggest mobile games in the world
that's totally free to play they've got a ton
of powerful new Champions this month like Grazer
iron good of the ogren tribes Al's score Crimson
Horn of The Barbarians created the blue of the
Sylvan Watchers whether you're looking for magic
defense or Force affinities they're all great for
balancing out your party they just debuted their
new raid called The Arbiter limited series and to
celebrate they're adding some of the characters
from the series as champions in the game that
you can play the first one is our attack the
orc warlord who they're giving away for free all
you have to do is log on to raid for seven days
between now and July 24th if you haven't seen call
The Arbiter episode 1 yet he's a badass you want
to check him out new episodes are released inside
the game every Thursday at 10 A.M eastern time
the finale scheduled for July 20th and all you
have to do to watch and just log into the game
you don't have to sign up for like the brilliant
streaming service which is kind of nice the series
gets into the wider lore of the game so if you're
a big fan of that it actually goes pretty deep on
it so be sure to check it out and remember to
log on for seven days to get our attack for
free on top of that players that are brand new
to the game can use my link in the description
or scan the QR code that I put on screen here
to get a free starter pack with a bunch of loot
when you use it the rewards will be in your inbox
up here so be sure to check it out it's actually
pretty cool series careful for spoilers for secret
Invasion episode one if you haven't seen it yet
but one of the big things Marvel is using secret
Invasion episodes for is to set up Nick Fury's
new saber space station as the next evolution
of what Shield used to be originally in the MCU
616 Universe Kevin feige destroyed Shield as an
organization basically during the Captain America
Winter Soldier movie the ID in the MCU is that
after that movie the government had been funding
it and basically just dismantled it which is why
you never really hear the characters talking a lot
about Shield after winter soldier that much
in the MCU damage control was kind of meant
to take its place as a sort of souped-up more
powerful version and now more Sinister version
of Homeland Security previously Shield had been
tasked with handling all earth-based matters now
damage control is basically taking that place and
before one division happened sword was tasked with
taking care of all space-based threats which is
pretty much the way it works in the comics Shield
handles all the stuff on planet Earth sword
handles everything coming from outer space
during the Agents of Shield TV show after winter
soldier they did their own version of the Hydra
reveal from their perspective Shield collapses at
organization and they slowly started doing more
Inhumans storyline their version of The Secret
Warriors from the comics which is more Inhumans
related stuff and after Avengers Infinity war and
Avengers end game they did their own time travel
story which were in the middle of with Kang in
Avengers 5 the Loki Series right now don't scratch
he's cleaning up the timelines recently Marvel
also organized the Agents of Shield TV show with
all its other MCU shows trying to say that some of
that stuff was still a Canon the same way they're
doing with the Netflix shows too like Daredevil
and Daredevil Born Again they're keeping a lot
of those old things still Canon with a couple of
creative retunings when they bring the characters
back but at the end of Agents of Shield they had
a teaser for what the characters were doing after
that and that was around the time the Avengers end
game was happening Mack took a leadership role in
a resurrected version of Shield becoming kind of a
Nick Fury type of character even wearing a similar
type of jacket you just had both eyes Coulson
had become an actual life model decoy version of
himself which is a big comic book Easter Egg but
he had all the memories of the original Coulson
Chloe Bennet's Quake character was running space
missions and that was meant to be their agents of
Sword teaser like the next evolution of Shield the
show ended before wand division in the collapse of
Sword they didn't go full Winter Soldier Hydra
with that but in the comics Nick Fury's space
station is run by Abigail brand for sword so
in the MCU they're saying that Nick Fury also
developed another side agency separate from sword
and because he's been building that saber space
station for years like it didn't happen overnight
it sounds like that predates the fall of Sword so
he always planned for the space station to
not be part of Sword they just brought the
Quake character back and Spider-Man across the
spider-verse of all places I was kind of Blown
Away by that I didn't believe it at first until it
was a bit of Zoom enhancing like nope yep that is
definitely quake in the back of Miles Morales and
genki's room inside their school they hang a bunch
of magazines a bunch of newspaper clippings if you
zoom and enhance here you can see on the wall is a
newspaper clipping taken from the Agents of Shield
TV show this is the exact same newspaper from the
live action Shield TV show and it's meant to be of
Chloe Bennet's Quake character I'm not expecting
Quake to suddenly appear as a big character in
Spider-Man beyond the spiderverse or anything
like that but clearly she's a character in Miles
Morales Universe I think the reason why she wound
up in across the spider versus probably because
one of the animators working on this particular
scene is an Agents of Shield fans like what can
we put on here that'll be cool Easter egg why
don't we put a Chloe Bennet Easter egg here a lot
of the Easter eggs in the spider-verse movies are
either canonical like big story based Easter eggs
that are meant to be big teasers for things and
others are just animators having fun so I think
in this case it was just an animator having fun
but now they're bringing so many of those original
Marvel TV actors back from the Netflix shows like
Daredevil Punisher Jessica Jones they brought
a younger Coulson back during the first Captain
Marvel movie people now asking when are they going
to bring quake and any of the other modern Shield
characters back because Nick Furious saber
space station through the secret Invasion the
Marvel's movie eventually the Young Avengers all
appropriate places to do that if she ended Agents
of Shield working for sword doing space missions
it would only make sense that she would be working
for Nick Fury at some point but remember that
teaser predated the fall of Sword during the One
Division Series so even if sword goes away she'd
still be doing missions for Nick Fury in real life
Chloe Bennet has been asked about coming back and
most of what she said most of her reactions are
standard Marvel actor speech if they want me back
I'd love to come back but I don't know what their
plans are for my character yada yada yada everyone
says that now it's like the standard Andrew
Garfield reaction nowadays in fact Tom Holland
recently joked that he is no longer the leader
of spoiler Bros and giving stuff away because
everyone else had been leaking stuff way more
than he had recently to be perfectly honest with
you I was actually the best at keeping secrets on
that third movie Andrew got caught ordering from
a deliveroo guy Toby got caught somehow Alfred
Molina was telling people in the supermarket that
he was doing the new Spider-Man show Willem Dafoe
got photographed at the airport so I was the one
that actually kept the secrets so let's end that
myth the other major change Kevin feige just
made a lot of you are asking about this too in
the MCU is sidestepping the whole Inhumans thing
during the Ms Marvel series during the series they
canonized Kamala Khan as a mutant played the X-Men
the Animated Series theme song and said that she
was not an inhuman then after the finale era they
made that big reveal the original creators of the
Kamala Khan character in her initial comic book
said that they had always planned to make her a
mutant but at the time that they were introducing
the character because Fox still owned the X-Men
IP the Marvel powers that be wouldn't let her
make her a mutant and said that she had to be
an inhuman instead if you don't remember this
was during the era when Ike Pearl Motor still
controlled Marvel everything and because they
didn't own the rights to X-Men they didn't want
X-Men to be a big thing so they were trying to
turn down the volume on X-Men mutant related
stuff at Marvel Comics just in general which is
why during that era it seems like they almost
published zero X-Men related Comics they still
published some but they turned the volume way way
down now that Marvel has all the X-Men rights
back then making kamalakana mutant in the MCU
seemed like a pretty clear sign that Kevin feige
is making a b line towards doing more mutants
and X-Men related stuff in the movies and TV shows
and not so much with the Inhumans they'll probably
find some way of doing inhuman stuff in the MCU
eventually but it just sounds like they don't have
any plans to do that right away during the Agents
of Shield TV show Quake was clearly an inhuman
like they had a very long Inhumans Arc if they
bring her character back in the MCU they might
do what they did for Daredevil born again and
Netflix character so Charlie Cox Vincent D'Onofrio
has talked about this a couple times saying that
most of the events from the original Daredevil
series are still Canon with a couple of minor
creative changes really good example of this is
Daredevil during the She-Hulk series when he was
wearing his classic comic book yellow in red suit
it was designed to look exactly like his Netflix
suit which is different colors so let me know in
the comics if they're making slight changes to
the characters and focusing more on X-Men mutant
related stuff not so much in humans do you think
that they would actually bring Quake back and try
to say that she was a mutant this whole time or
do you think that they would just continue saying
that she's an inhuman it was a little bit easier
for them to do that during the Ms Marvel series
because before that there had been no live-action
Kamala Khan character if we do wind up seeing any
of the shield characters come back during secret
Invasion I'm not expecting it till like the very
end of the series and it might not be till the
future of the MCU if we see any more Shield Easter
eggs of course I'll do videos about it though my
full secret Invasion Episode 2 video will post
this Wednesday after it comes out remember there
are six episodes total congratulations pixie 232
you're the giveaway winner from my last big
Marvel video please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your contact
details everyone click here for all my secret
Invasion episodes and click here to learn about
Ben Affleck's Daredevil coming back in Deadpool
3. thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!